so let me hear Michael do I'll do and
what I want to hear I'll tell you it's
something oh this dude right for the
last two three years three years three
years we've been doing this podcast Oh
three years oh yeah he does a thing
where he introduces the this portion of
the show and he does his deep Michael
Clarke Duncan voice which is great and
people love it but I wanted him to do a
different voice because I'm just tired
of hearing it and now he's done it twice
and he doesn't want to do it the way I
want to do it I love to go back so which
one you want to do I'll start off with
you let's do one more year of Michael
Clarke Duncan I guess what mark next
year you don't have to change it okay so
go ahead I'll go first bus with body
kalila and Johnny but crickets and
chains hey guys love you all I'm a
thirty year old girl and I have a
boyfriend we have two kids I've been
waiting to get a tattoo on my arm
eventually a sleeve but worried about
what my parents will say I have five
tattoos but they are in places where
it's not invisible unless I'm wearing a
bikini I don't know why I'm still
worried or I feel like I'm gonna get in
trouble with them even though I don't
live with them anymore my question is
how do I get over not caring about what
my parents think Tanisha I don't know
because I don't I've never had that
mm-hmm like my parents I don't my
parents have never they've said if you
could tattoo you no longer my son
they've had those conversations if you
gay
you know don't ever quarter me those
kind of things those crazy broad you
know threat and I'd be like no you're
gonna be my dad yeah these are just
words could you love me just do it just
do it you're not gonna not love you I
love you for 30 years there's no back
out now because of some ink on your skin
Johnny loves white chicks and his
parents probably were like hey you know
will you did you know dude have you seen
that meme why Mexican dudes like white
girls no with the it's got a white
girl's arm with freckles and right next
to it is a huge burrito with the same
spotting
tortilla the tortilla has the same spot
it's white with around the freckles dude
I died when I saw ya there's a meme like
that I have the same yeah it's great I
gotta look it up gotta leave with what
Google mean why why Mexican guys like
white girls or mean with meme white
girls in burrito yeah white girls yeah
it's because it's the tortilla but it is
a burrito so it looks like her arm
burrito okay see if I can find it yeah
why Mexican guys that's so true oh my
god is so oh you know how much I like
Fred the more freckles the better yeah
you have this weird thing with white
chicks and then the the right white is
that a lie
oh my god you've never gave it a latin
girl I've never seen you with one I had
one my very first one in eighth grade
for a year and then what was it she was
you know she was hot but like I felt
like there was a there was a little bit
of a cultural break to just her family
was a little more like her brothers and
stuff like wow hey you gonna do it yeah
there was like a difference in the and
the families and yes she was very punchy
you know what I'm saying she'd get mad
she started hitting and punch
yeah yeah yeah and I was like ah and
then I had a got a white girlfriend like
my freshman I was like oh this is all
right
whoa this is we're heavy yeah the man
dream Freck how about that Alex Morgan
on the soccer game for what did you ask
what do you mean she's from here it's
you like Diamond Bar it she's Kelly
yes she's California yeah man so what
what you're telling me right now is if
Alex Morgan just called you out of the
blue after winning the World Cup after
winning the whoa she's gonna call
Johnny's
[Music]
yeah and you said that maybe but what if
she's like you're not gonna believe this
I've had this weird fascination with
insects for years and I'm totally gone
by crickets right
[Music]